an unbelievable story Google has a lot
of explaining to do if you googled the
California Republican Party lately the
information Bach would inform you about
the party's ideology what it said is
jaw-dropping let's examine it with House
Majority Leader Kevin McCarthy
Republican from California it's great to
see you
Majority Leader McCarthy what is going
on Google said that this was a mistake
but you've got wind of this and when you
typed in California Republican Party
what showed up it said our ideology was
Nazism it wasn't the party of Lincoln
it wasn't the party of Reagan it's
suddenly were Nazis and remember Google
is the largest search engine in the
world
ninety percent of all internet searches
goes through Google and this is what
they said the California Republican
Party was now I got wind of this so I
went to see are they pulling it from
Wikipedia and I went over to Wikipedia
for the California Republicans it did
not say Nazism and so it concerns me
greatly because this isn't the only
situation the bias that is happening
here if you searched on Instagram for
Donald Trump jr. this weekend you know
what it told you it warned you that his
site could cause you harm or even death
then Amazon kicked off the alliance for
defending freedom to give their charity
program Amazon smile where if you're if
you're conservative and you're
purchasing something there you can send
some charity money to a non-profit they
removed them because the Southern
Poverty Law decided they weren't good
that people who defend religious freedom
before the Supreme Court that Southern
Poverty Law Center has turned into a
left-wing rabid radical group that tries
to you know malign people myself
included because we stand up for against
Christians being persecuted in the
Middle East and now we're anti Islam
okay it's ridiculous so what can be done
google says this they blame Wikipedia in
their statement with it they release
they said they usually catch vandalism
congressman afford impact search results
but occasionally errors get through and
that's what happened here you know they
gave that explanation after we went
forward and public with it but I had
already searched Wikipedia
it wasn't on the Wikipedia page so this
is why we need transparency this bias
against conservatives has to stop and
they always they always explain it away
or something small no I want to know did
an employee in there go forward and put
the idea that the party of Lincoln that
brought us Ronald Reagan they decided we
were Nazis that's unacceptable yeah well
yeah good so it's a liberal culture
there in Silicon Valley certainly at
Google I want to move on to other topics
a lot of conversation on Capitol Hill
about who's gonna be the next speaker
your name is always at the top of the
list but your friends over there in the
LA Times yesterday said why California's
Kevin McCarthy is having a hard time
locking down the speaker's job again
what what's happening here well
congressman from North Carolina's name
mentioned who you know I don't even know
who's that what's his name I don't even
know his name but we have other people's
names mentioned but what's going on yeah
well one there's no speaker race right
now it's Paul Ryan decided that he's not
gonna run for reelection so after the
election we will have won but what's
most important here is we have to focus
to make sure we can have a Republican to
be Speaker I feel very confident that
race going forward that I can win that
vote inside conference but my whole
focus right now is making sure we're
winning the majority and that's why I
traveling the country defending the
individuals and making sure we have the
resources to win because remember what
we've been able to accomplish here
unemployment at 18 year low we just
reformed the VA
look what we did last week alone right
to try for those for those sick
individuals being able to have a new
medication that hasn't been approved yet
dodd-frank then we just did prison
reform and we also did the NDA national
defense that was just that week are you
guys gonna do an amnesty no we're not
gonna be an amnesty we're gonna we're
going to no we're going to protect our
borders because we know and you know so
well this idea of the current system
right now is broken you got to be able
to one build the wall you got to end
catch and release we got to have a
system that's based upon merit yeah if
we really want this country to grow and
it's not very simple
I mean yeah well the good lab buildings
are that's bill but is John Cox have a
chance in California is the GOP have
reason to hope in California yes look we
have a lot of hope remember remember
this is a state that brought us Ronald
Reagan John Cox will come through we
have this crazy system of chattering
back which I do not like this idea is
crazy John Cox will come through but
there's another reason for California to
be hopeful the Democrats when they took
the majority they raised a gasoline tax
twelve cents I don't have an initiative
on the ballot that you could repeal that
got it got it yeah we got to bring hope
back to the people of California
especially Republicans congressman thank
you so much for joining us